[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the
second episode of queen trap sec lines
in this episode I'm going to show you a
game where the recent world championship
challenger Sergey Kuryakin crushed in
just 11 moves by a wonderful Queen
sacrifice line even though it was a
blitz game the opening ideas and its
plants and patterns are what's
remembering in your own game and reckon
who was writing this petition start with
the Moosey fool and black respond with
the mu e phi we have three nights
english opening is on the board where
why I decided to tell in the center with
d4 here black has plenty of choices but
in the game he decided to dissolve the
tension immediately with he captures d4
well the normal move over here is Knight
captures d4 but white in this game all
said to surprise his opponent with this
tricky move Knight to d5
and I think black has to play already
some careful moves to avoid lots of
tricks and traps for example a careless
moves such as Knight G to e7 leads to
the instant disaster after this
finishing blow Knight to f6 and this is
a picture is checkmate what happens if
black plays Knight C to e7 well then he
has to deal with this horrible move
Queen captures g4
finally the normal-looking move Knight
to f6 is not possible in this case the
simple reason is after Bishop to g5
the spin is very deadly and if black
tries to break the pain with Bishop to
e7 then he has to postpone his plan for
a castling for a long time after Bishop
26 so considering all this factor
kayaking decided to play the routine
development move Bishop to g7 which
doesn't turns out very well
white initiative rolled on the board
with Bishop to g5 attacking the Queen
here the best reply is night C to e7
afterwards white will continue with the
move Knight to d4 with a very good
initiative other moves such as Knight to
f6 or f6 are not good at all
for example after the move f6 a sample
line can run like this
Bishop to f4 attacking on c7 d6 and now
Knight captures d4 where white threads
are going on and black has a very funny
King side position in the game black
decided to continue with Knight G to e7
but I think this is already a serious
mistake as after the simple looking move
Knight catches default create a huge
problem for the black for example here
Knight captures V 4 is not possible the
simple reason is after Bishop to e7
it's a bye-bye miss black queen hahaha
so that's straight out of the window
move such as f6 doesn't work either
because after the falling continuation
that is Bishop captures f6 Bishop takes
Knight check King to f7 and now Knight
to e4 and not only black is a clear pond
down but on top of everything he had
this naked King so the problem is now
what to do because now what is
threatening a simple sequence that is
Knight captures c6 and Bishop takes c7
so that means black has to do something
with this pesky night
as a world-class GM not expecting this
kind of pressure in the opening karyakin
decided to continue here with Bishop
captures deform and thought that he can
get away with this move but White's next
reply give him the rude shock I think
you already guessed it right yeah it's a
wonderful Queen sir Queen captures d4
first important point black cannot take
this Queen because after Knight captures
d4 White has this forcing checkmate that
is night Jack King to her fate and now
Bishop to head six is a deadly anger so
often in chess one mistake followed by
the other and here black already annoyed
by his mistake continue with this
disaster blunder castle on the Kings
side thinking that my king is safe there
and I'm attacking on the Queen but what
he missed is now white can forcefully
checkmate the black king before I mourn
I like you to pause this video and find
out a forcing sequence where why can
checkmate the black ink did you find it
let's see the forcing sequence start
with the move Knight check here black
King has to go to the eighth square as
after King to g7 the simplest checkmate
is night to H Phi a double discover Jack
King to g8 and now Quinn to g7 is a
checkmate so in the game kayaking played
King to h8 and now the important mating
sequence move Knight to g4 giving a
check with the Queen even though white
queen is hanging again black cannot take
it because after the simple sequence
that is Knight captures d4 Bishop check
King to g8 and once again this deadly
checkmate night 2 at 6:00
and it doesn't matter however black
plays there is a checkmate in three guys
in the game karyakin decided to get the
fastest checkmate that is after King to
g8 and night two at six
it's a checkmate but instead of that if
he had continued with the mu Epsilon
sequence that is Bishop f6 check row cap
six Queen check King to g8 and now
Knight to at six finished the King once
and for all
what a wonderful miniature by white
it proves that opening surprises are
worth the element in your preparation
and the day it works it can eliminate
any super Grandmaster within few moves
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on my video and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care